moins de 2 ans pouvoir se sont écoulés
dimanche Justin Trudeau prévoit se
rendre de nouveau chez la gouverneur
général pour dissoudre le Parlement et
plonger une pays dans une campagne
électorale
pour
le
20 septembre
mais c'est
parti mais ce n'est pas ce que les gens
veux voir
mets le MPD se dit prêt à se battre
jogging est déjà en mode électoral il a
dévoilé une série d'engagement comme une
taxe spéciale pour les Canadiens les
plus fortunés note révision c'est on
doit s'assurer que les autres le juste
par pour investir dans les gens mais je
début d'une 4e vague de covid-19 qui
augmente dans plusieurs fois Vince Oros
exposé à la critique
[Musique]
c'est trop tôt c'est trop tôt encore à
la lecture des sondages le premier
ministre. Il risque calculer salon 7
experts
analysons cette décision avec notre chef
de bureau à Ottawa fait prête pour une
élection Madeleine Bonsoir
les sondages en ce moment ils sont en
avance et le calendrier leur offre une
fenêtre qui ne se représentera pas si
ton selon eux s'ils veulent pas chez
vous j'ai d'autres rendez-vous
électoraux par exemple il va y avoir des
élections municipales au Québec un peu
plus tard cet automne il va y avoir des
élections provinciales en Ontario le
printemps prochain donc il voit la
fenêtre maintenant ils sont en avance
mais en même temps pendant la pandémie
vous avez pratiquement toute la
patinoire à eux on suivait les points de
presse de Justin Trudeau aller à
l'opposition donc là avec le
déclenchement des élections et les
libéraux vont devoir automatiquement
partager avec l'opposition ça va être
une occasion pour par exemple de la
difficulté à se vendre au Canadien donc
c'est pas pour rien Alexis que les
libéraux décide d'avoir une courte
campagne et la voudrais sous la
langue parle pas de vague de covit là
parce que il aurait sûrement
de vitesse une quatrième vague ils vont
devoir composer avec cette réalité là ça
risque peut-être de faire dévier
certaines leur plan et ils vont devoir
se justifier de tenir ce que tu as comme
ça pendant une pandémie mais quand on
leur parle [ __ ] saison des jeunes
réponse te prête en disant qu'en 2019
électoraux rien à voir avec la pandémie
et que là on entre dans un moment
charnière avec l'idée de devoir mettre
fin à cette pandémie l'heure de penser à
l'après donc ils se sentent justifier de
solliciter on autrement puisque vous
parlez Madeleine de la crise sanitaire
de la pandémie ça sera la première
élection nationale en tant qu' il y a
plusieurs province au cours des derniers
mois mais cette fois-ci à l'échelle
nationale à quoi ça risque de ressembler
de position peu partie du gouvernement
peux quand même regarder ce qui se fait
en Colombie-Britannique en Saskatchewan
au Nouveau-Brunswick à Terre-Neuve aussi
là où il y a eu quand même des défis en
fin de campagne a été reporté donc en ce
moment là on t'attend quand même à ce
que les leaders visite toutes les
régions du pays mets le mode en ce sera
quand même flexibilité parce que ils
vont devoir se peigner au conseil de
santé publique des différentes provinces
et que ça va donner ça faudra voir par
exemple Justin Trudeau site carburant à
l'énergie des foules là il va devoir se
contenter de plus petit rassemblement
mais évidemment ça va être une campagne
qui va être différente et une campagne
avec peut-être un scrutin qui sera plus
long le secrétaire une dépouillement des
votes sera plus long à si on a plus de
vote par la poste notamment
incontournable de cette campagne
électorale imminente
d'emploi de difficile aussi le NPD on
voyait dans le reportage là on est déjà
dévoilé
programme électoral avec cette idée de
taxer les profits excessif là c'est
l'expression d'une paix des des des
grandes entreprises et 3 questions
d'environnement nécessairement la
pandémie on n'y échappera pas non mais
en même temps Alexis même si 3 questions
au début de campagne de cette idée de
déclencher scrutin en pleine Pandini le
position pour rapport pendant 36 jours
Christine gouvernement d'avoir
déclencher inscrire maintenant parce que
ça serait comme une partie de base-ball
où les joueurs dirai pendant toute la
partie nous on veut pas jouer donc je
resterai de rester sur le bain mais
qu'est-ce que la question de Lyon ça
c'est très très difficile de déterminer
surtout avant même que le tien il ne
soit déclenché donc les élections le
déclenchement c'est prévu pour dimanche
on aura 5 semaines pour se parler des
enjeux et se parler de la question de
l'urne avec
comme toujours et sera ça sera surveillé
sur nos ondes donc des images merci
beaucoup Madeleine